the framers adopted the first amendment  in order to protect Free Speech but none  of them ever thought that the First  Amendment protected every single Grunt  and Belch and sound that might come out  of the mouths of their fellow countrymen  the founders and the framers were not  free speech absolutists by any stretch  of the imagination from the earliest  days of our nation all sorts of speech  was illegal and out of bounds  threats fraud fighting words obscenity  blasphemy even until about a decade ago  many states in our country had laws  against blasphemy some states in fact  still have those laws  and we were better off for it as far as  I'm concerned